-Our first two guests tonight
are two talented actors
and family members who star in
the hit Apple TV+ series
"Monarch: Legacy of Monsters."
The final episode of the season
is available to stream
this Friday, January 12th.
Let's take a look.
-[ Speaking foreign language ]
-Shaw!
-Get me Bill Randa!
-Let her go!
-Go get me Bill Randa!
-I can't.
He's dead.
We're in the Monarch
medical facility.
You disappeared during
Operation Hourglass in 1962.
♪♪
20 years ago.
-Please welcome to the show
Kurt Russell and Wyatt Russell,
everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back, gentlemen.
-Hey!
-Good to be here in person.
-I'm so -- Yeah.
I've only spoken
to you on Zoom, Wyatt.
It's great to have you
in the studio.
And, Kurt, it's been a while
since you were here.
-I know.
-But you're a man of your word.
Last time you were here,
we were talking about
your vineyard and your wine,
and you promised to bring me
some wine, and you did.
-Well, you guys
figured that out.
-So we're gonna have some.
-He's ready to go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I have some, uh...
Well, first, cheers
to you guys here.
Happy new year.
-Yeah.
Hey, it's great
to see you again.
-Thank you, thank you.
-This is Gogi Wine,
but is this La Mer?
-This is La Mer. Yeah.
-La Mer is named
after Meredith Hagner,
Wyatt Russell's wife.
-Yes. Your lovely wife --
an incredibly talented
and funny actress.
-Smarter, funnier.
Every adjective you could use.
-Mother of our
seventh grandchild.
-You have seven grandchild --
-And soon to be eight.
-You're about to have eight.
Congratulations.
I know you're about
to have your second.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Life's about to
change big time.
-Real quick, obviously
you've seen your father
as a grandparent with other --
your siblings' grandkids --
or their children.
-Yes.
-How is he as a grandparent?
-He's -- He's awesome,
'cause he can do all of the --
all of the hard sort of lessons
that, like,
sometimes
I don't want to have to do.
But luckily he doesn't hide any
of who he is to who my son is.
So there was, like --
We were going on a street
when I was living in Vancouver
shooting "Monarch,"
and Buddy wants to test going
on the street, and my dad goes,
"No, no, no!"
-No, no!
-Buddy lost it.
He was crying.
And I'm like, "Well, I don't
know. It's a good lesson."
Comes back, he's like,
"What does Gogi say?"
Buddy goes, "No, no, no,"
points it's the street.
And I was like, "Yes!
You got it." Like thanks, Pop.
-So, wait. So, is Gogi
both the name of the wine
and your grandparent name?
-Yes.
See, I grew up as Gogo.
-Okay.
-My middle name was Vogel.
I couldn't pronounce it
when I was a little kid,
so I was Gogo.
-So everybody called you Gogo.
-I'm Gogo.
And then one day, when I was
very early on with Goldie,
my dad, who called me Goge,
said, "Hey, Goge,"
and we both turned around
and she looked, and she said,
"How did you know my nickname?"
She grew up as Gogo.
-No way!
-My nickname Gogo turned
into, via my sisters,
a lot of different versions
of Gogo, Goginshki...
-Yeah.
-...and Gogi.
Gogi was the sort of
what I became
to all the grandkids
and to all my family.
-It's really funny that
at a very young age
you had a perfect
grandfather name.
-[ Laughs ]
-Like you've grown into Gogo
very well.
Because, like, when you meet
like a four year old
called Gogo, you're like,
"What's this kid getting up to?"
[ Laughter ]
-So it's Gogo and Gogi
to all the grandkids
and...
-And now what is it like
watching Wyatt as a father?
How's that transformation?
-That's a problem. But...
-Yeah.
-[ Laughs ]
-I mean, obviously his kids
don't know streets are bad.
[ Indistinct ]
-Guy's an idiot.
-[ Indistinct ]
I got to say,
they're great parents.
No, I thought I was going to say
he's a great grandparent
because he's hands-off.
-[ Laughs ]
But it's like...
Uh, no, it's fun to watch,
it really is,
with all of our kids.
with Ollie and Kate's kids,
and Uncle Boston comes over
to everybody's house.
It's -- You know,
we are very fortunate.
-Uh, obviously,
Wyatt looks up to you
because he also has
his own cocktail.
-Oh, yeah. That's right.
-It's not wine.
This is Lake Hour.
-Lake Hour.
-This is a vodka cocktail
in a can.
-That's right.
-Yes.
Honeysuckle...
uh, honeysuckle ginger.
-It is born here in New York.
-Alright.
-Ooh!
Ooh, we're moving
right along here.
-I assumed you start
with the wine,
and then you move
to the drink in a cam.
-[ Laughs ]
-Yeah. I was gonna make a joke.
I was like, "The guy in that
clip needed a Lake Hour."
-[ Indistinct ]
-Yeah, there you go.
-Cheers.
-Two-fister here.
Great seeing you guys.
-Cheers.
-Cheers. Good to see you guys.
-Hey, have a happy new!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Delicious.
-Yeah.
Nice and light
and refreshing.
-I was very jealous
when we spoke
because your three-year-old's
name is Buddy Prine,
which is a fantastic name.
-Thank you.
-And, uh, his birthday,
December 26th.
I sympathize with him.
December 28th.
-Oh, really?
-So I know the feeling.
Although, the 26th
seems even worse.
Does he appreciate...?
-No, no, dude.
So -- So it was -- It was --
We do Christmas, 25th of Chris--
25th of, you know.
We wake up, we do the Christmas.
It's nuts. It's a disaster
most of the day.
It's great most of the day.
Goes to sleep, wake up.
Mer and I are like,
"Okay, Buddy.
Buddy, it's your birthday!"
Like, "Gotta get excited."
And he goes -- And he's three,
and he goes, "Ugh! Not now."
[ Laughter ]
We're like, "You got it!
That's the right answer!
You're learning well.
Like, no one wants to celebrate
your birthday."
-A three-year-old who actually
has an understanding of excess
is pretty great.
-Yes, exactly.
He's like, "Enough is enough."
-Enough is enough.
-Well, I think it was --
a very cool thing for him
is that his dad
and his grandfather
are in
a television show together.
We're going to talk about
that next.
We'll be right back
with Kurt and Wyatt after this.